hello
reject
nation
today we're going to talk about
the um
trial
of uh
johnny depp
[Music]
versus amber heard
for getting all serious up in here had
to do my classic beating to death johnny
depp impression anywho guys
i don't need to tell you all johnny depp
versus amber heard trial the defamation
lawsuit has been going on where uh
johnny depp is suing amber hurd for that
op-ed piece of did amber heard defame
him in that article and uh it's been a
fascinating one needless to say a whole
lot more has come out and the
conversation is about way more than just
that
understandably and rightfully so but
it's it's been pretty much my like new
religion is absorbing this entire trial
i believe i've heard every second up
until the last witness testimony you
know it's still ongoing uh but the when
i when i most recently turned it off
which was just very like
20 minutes ago the last time johnny depp
was testifying i haven't been doing
videos about it truth be told that i
wasn't planning on even talking about it
as much as i've been
absorbing it and hearing all of it i
really wasn't planning on doing videos
about it i had a lot of
friends who i discussed this just case
with in depth because there's a jury
there but we're all playing jury
ourselves right now anyone who's really
following this trial as much as i've
been asked like why haven't you been
talking about it i have a lot of
my own
personal reasons as to why some of you
might know that in the past i've i've
tried touching on it i just get like my
chest with tightening up i forget those
like feelings of like i'm on stage or
something like my throat would it would
tie it and the the subject of domestic
violence is a subject i take incredibly
serious i really do i take it very very
seriously to frank right now the feeling
i'm having is that normally when i come
on camera i want to be like all
energetic and positive but after
listening to the the last uh last bits
of him testifying i'm again left with
the feeling that i keep doing to myself
because i can't stop listening to this
trial is
i feel like a little bit hollow
a little bit down get that feeling like
my heart just kind of hurts a little bit
i don't quite know how to describe it
i'm usually pretty eloquent at
describing my feelings and i know this
is a sensitive subject for a lot of
people this subject in particular is an
incredibly sensitive one and i i
completely understand like when it comes
to this subject depending on one's own
traumas and how far they've come and
overcoming their traumas a lot can be
applied here like a lot can be projected
onto how they're receiving the
information and the opinions that they
actually form what's cool about getting
a trial
is you get a lot of facts to work off of
instead and if you're able to kind of
separate yourself which i know is very
easier said than done but if you're able
to separate yourself and just listen to
the information it might be easier on
forming an opinion i'm not here to say
i'm right you're wrong i'm here to just
share my thoughts i'm not going to do a
full breakdown of the situation there's
been other channels channels have been
covering this
this situation in particular for years
who are now
really covering it uh extensively and
are doing a wonderful job so if you want
like in-depth analysis breakdown of it
please go and check them out i'm here to
just kind of share my feelings on it
right now as especially as someone who
in the very beginning when amber heard
did to have her photos go out of looking
all bruised i'm not gonna lie to you
guys i
instantly believed amber hurt and i
believed her for quite a long time
without really diving into the subject
it's a big reason why johnny depp is
fighting you know most cases with
celebrities this is i think is a good
point to be made most cases when it
comes to [ __ ] like this if if the person
actually did do the bad deed
they just kind of wanted to settle out
of court and just let it die down johnny
depp has been fighting tooth and nail
and is now freaking so public about it
all this stuff that's happening after
so many years i think there's an element
of that where you gotta you gotta at
least question does that lend credence
in my opinion it does link line credence
to the argument maybe he's just fighting
to restore his reputation so he could
get the work back and get the money back
maybe i don't have the opinion that that
is the case well i know there's a touchy
subject i did feel compelled to hop on
camera
and kind of share my feelings on this
for a few reasons that we'll explore as
i continue to talk when i first heard
about this i did decide with amber heard
and around the time when james gunn was
fired from disney i went on twitter and
i said some [ __ ] about disney and part
of that i lumped in johnny depp and
instantly there were some followers who
immediately were like i'm disappointed
in you craig how do you not know about
that like i didn't know about anything
and this was years ago when this
happened
like much less evidence available to the
public years ago and i just chalked it
up to johnny depp wild superfans people
who just can't possibly see that the
precious famous celebrity is a horrible
human being and this is coming from a
guy who
loved johnny depp like i
loved the [ __ ] out of johnny depp the
longest time i deemed him my number one
favorite actor was obsessed with his
filmography when i started to actually
read some of the things in my inbox
where there was like screenshots of
court documents and whatnot going
through it i started to question you
know what what is what is the truth here
and then over the years channels like
incredibly average and more
have been bringing to light
so much more evidence
to show that there was
a lot of lies actually happening here
most likely i believe it's been a lot of
lies i did start to find myself going i
really don't believe johnny depp beat
the [ __ ] out of amber heard i just don't
believe it i don't believe that happened
it's fascinating to see this trial
unfold and it's being so massive right
now i remember
when all these audios that have been out
for a long time that are now being
played in this trial are becoming
headlines
and you know the titles of videos for
the major news outlets the major media
outlets and for so long people were
saying
why don't the big outlets report on this
why don't the big outlets share this why
don't they bring this to light one of
the good things about this trial is that
it is bringing it to light it's been
slowly that the court of public opinion
has been swaying more to johnny depp's
side and then after the uk trial even
though he lost that trial he seemed to
have won over a lot of people still
but then here
now that we all get a play jury along
with the jury it seems like the court of
public opinion is much more
predominantly in johnny depp's favor
that's not to say there aren't people
who side with amber heard there's i'm
not sure there's a lot of people who are
still like i'm waiting to hear amber
herg get on the stand i'm sure there's a
lot of people like that but unless amber
heard's team suddenly starts doing a
good job a because they've been doing
just a [ __ ] job unless they start doing
a good job and b unless they pull out
some some like remarkable piece of
evidence to support their case i don't
see them swaying the court of public
opinion i just don't see it happening
i'm happy for johnny depp in that regard
like of course that this situation is
not a pleasant one and it's an
unfortunate one and really a very
depressing one it's good that this trial
is happening because a lot of people
will say that johnny depp's career from
here on out definitely it was already
ruined and now it's definitely ruined
and that he's not going to be able to
really work again i'm hoping this does
lead to the firing of amber hurt again
in case something does happen to come
out that completely flips
my opinion on this i'm on the side of
like i think amber should be getting
fired from the dc universe or wb to say
the least throughout this trial one
thing it's done is really shift the
narrative you know in the beginning it
was painted like amber heard who was
this you know fragile woman
who lived with this monster who just
beat the crap out of her and he's an
alcoholic and a drug addict and he's
he's the one who really was the this
monster right now
it's very apparent amber heard was not
the individual she tried to paint
herself as there's just far too much
evidence to support it been a lot that
can be character assassination
especially regarded towards johnny depp
of how they'll try to like isolate text
messages exchanges like these little
things with and not allow for additional
context like what was leading to this
conversation why did this happen why was
it said you know it was just like did
you know you said it okay let me cut
them up just move one up moving on right
while that happens giant depth a lot not
everything like there's a lot of things
that obviously don't paint him in a good
light clearly there's a lot that doesn't
there's a lot of things that have been
very telling of amber heard especially
though main thing though the main thing
because i want to talk on this subject a
little bit more in just a second
is like while definitely emotional abuse
was very much on display and verbal
abuse um from both of their sides i'm
going to talk about that a little bit
more in a second main thing is is like
all that [ __ ] about like did he hit her
did he break her nose um you know did
give her black eyes the concussions
ripping chunks of hair out all that
plain and simple doesn't seem like it
happened it's just just don't i don't
believe it i don't believe johnny depp
did that it's like having emotional and
verbal abuse in a relationship is one
thing when you get all physical like
that where you're really like life
threatening to that degree it's like
sure trauma can form from emotional
verbal abuse undoubtedly it can it can
make it last for years upon years upon
years the physical abuse that's the main
question at hand here i don't think he
did i really don't believe he did and i
believe a lot of the things that first i
just didn't and then over the years like
i believed a lot of this beforehand this
trial is only solidifying it even with
as much new things come to light it just
really goes to show my opinion at least
is that she's light of the court i do
believe she stole that charity money
she's lied about physical assault her
stories sometimes don't seem to be
consistent they seem to contradict one
another sometimes just the way like
amber heard's team is they they just
seem
desperate and they seem kind of scared
of johnny i don't know what's factoring
in there maybe they are afraid or they
are star struck in a way or maybe
they're like oh my god everyone's really
against my client um i'm a little
nervous about it bottom line is if they
really had a good case on their hands i
don't feel like the lack of confidence
would really show like there's been some
laughable [ __ ] that really happens
especially in the cross-examination
parts so when it comes back to the main
case of it all did amber her defame
giant ben's article like she has to
prove that he was like domestically
violent the one piece of evidence that
they seem to really try to lean in on
was that video where you know johnny
depp was even unsure what exactly
happened that day according to his
testimony where he's in the kitchen and
he's being aggressive with items you
know he's like that joke about like i
abused cabinets you know in all fairness
he it seemed like he's getting pretty
rough like if i happen to stumble in to
a situation like that with any man there
or even a woman doing that i'd be a
little bit scared like uh are they gonna
break some stuff right now i mean are
they gonna get violent sure like i
understand that so
that seemed to be the one thing they
were trying to lean in on and they hey
they don't really lean into that if i'm
not mistaken you know if you put someone
in that situation where they're
at let's say like i'm in the room with
my fiance and then i start like slamming
some [ __ ]
breaking some things kicking some things
or whatever if she's feeling scared or
i'm exposing her to me destroying stuff
that can qualify as a form of abuse
absolutely but then again what we're
going to think about is like context
surrounding the things i'm not even
talking about why johnny depp's even
doing that with this whole video that
played out it didn't seem like he went
into
the room and started going after amber
seemed like he was isolated by himself
and then she interjected herself in
there with a camera and then when he did
snatch the camera away and was really
pissed off about being secretly recorded
without his consent without being told
that she picked up the camera and you
could see her smiling about it like a
gotchu moment and there's just something
about that additional context that just
seems off about it like she doesn't
actually seem like she was scared during
that situation
he wasn't going after her she put
herself in that room with him and it's
not like they have a two-bedroom house
or something like that you know like i'm
pretty sure where [ __ ] johnny depp
and hamburg are living is a pretty big
place i'm not saying it's right with
what's happening but it's kind of hard
for me to feel like what he's doing was
being abusive towards her in that moment
if that makes sense i think this
obviously was a very toxic relationship
and there's a lot of emotional and
verbal abuse that's happening between
them the most common rhetoric that seems
to be happening in all these audios i
keep coming out
is something that i think happens in a
lot of toxic relationships when one
partner has a big fear of abandonment
and they feel like
that they can't separate themselves from
a fight or an argument because they're
worried the other person will leave and
abandon them and this is the case where
amber hurt has admitted to
literally physically assaulting him
hitting him physically harming the guy
and admitting that she instigates it and
starts it and she has reasons as to why
she does it a lot of us already are very
much aware of that that it's like all
the evidence seems to support that she
instigates she starts it and she also
traps in the middle of a fight the
mature thing would be to separate and go
let's take a little breather from each
other let's take a little break come
back with cooler heads that way we can
actually try to talk this out the other
person though in the middle of a really
heated argument and that fear that
trauma's coming up in them they do
something very abusive and toxic and
trap them into that situation
and think in mistaking that for like i'm
fighting for love when that's really not
the case so my point being is that
obviously there's evidence of like
johnny depp not just in those text
message exchanges where some of it is
just jokes and some of it is just
straight up mean and crude uh towards
amber heard there is some audio that is
out there of him saying some mean things
to amber herd directly the part of it
though that i feel like gets especially
touchy though normally at least in the
situations that i'm usually hearing
about or that i've been privy to myself
normally it's gender flipped normally
it's the the husband is definitely the
instigator and the one to fear um while
the the woman is the one who has to who
becomes like reactionary abusive back
like when they start fighting back after
being pushed to that certain point so
while it's easy to look at that and go
they're both
they're both emotionally abusive they're
both verbally abusive like the the fact
is that yeah there are definite
instances of such a case but there is
such a thing as reactionary abuse when
you get to a point where you get pushed
so much to a point where you have to
start fighting back a little bit but
finding back does not mean he beat the
[ __ ] out of her and that's the part that
really damaged johnny depp's career and
just a straight up lie plenty of things
that point to the fact that amber heard
faked those marks on her face even the
defense trying to use that whole thing
with like the milani cosmetics and
saying like you know she uses milani
cosmetics but then milani came out and
was like you know when that situation
happened our product wasn't even on the
market then so there's no way that that
was the case like so you can't use this
in your trial i think what's happened in
this trial with all facts presented all
evidence supported testimony whatever it
really seems like and this is what i
believe the whole image that amber heard
was able to successfully paint about
johnny depp for a long time the thing
that really damaged his image his
reputation his career of him being this
controlling
violent menace is just not true and so i
get why he's fighting again like i said
unless amber her match pulls him out of
her ass i'm really hoping johnny depp
wins this trial because we don't know
what the jury will ultimately vote you
know they might look at this and go
what's the trial actually about really
like ruminate on it so we don't know
what'll ultimately lead into we don't
know who's on that jury but the court of
public opinion really seems to be in
giada's favor with that being said you
know because so much of this is like a
fight for optics at the same time i
think that amber heard ought to be fired
from aquaman too soon as i've had to do
this time and time again lately it seems
like replace amber just get a different
actress reshoot that [ __ ] i know it'll
cost you some money but do it because
you're probably going to lose money by
keeping her in there so replace amber
hurt it's just not fair secondly there
is that narrative out there that you
know a lot of people feel like because
jindab's put so much out on his personal
life things that don't paint him in a
good light but in spite of that i still
think he's innocent in the things he's
fighting for i'm hoping
that after all is said and done
whatever the outcome of the trial might
be within a few years time the giant
depth can go back to doing
what we all knew giant depth for which
was being a freaking awesome actor you
know like i
i i remember thinking uh around i don't
exactly know when but there was a point
after like pirates or house in
wonderland type when i was like you know
johnny depp just seems like he's
starting to lose it a little bit in
terms of like his acting abilities
probably have like a certain hit here or
there like a really good performance
here or there he seemed like he was
really losing a lot of that spark and
passion
and start becoming like a joke in and of
himself i don't know how much of his uh
ability on camera correlates with his
relationship with amber hurt or whatnot
but i believe in a good comeback story
and i 100
believe he deserves a comeback and i
think you know with the work johnny depp
has done in the past he's a good enough
actor a damn fine actor to the point
where i think he can get to the point
where we can see past some of the
personal life stuff and just see him as
an actor again just look at the
character he's playing and not think
about johnny f the person who we saw on
trial pouring his heart and soul
fighting for what was right after the
legacy that he he was building up a
strong legacy uh to leave behind and
then it got tainted and really stained
by this situation
where a lot of it just seems like a
bunch of [ __ ] plain and simple i'm
sorry for like what his family said how
to go through him i feel terrible for
what he's had to go through you know i
do side with johnny on this
like i really do that's just my thoughts
um not really not in this
i just had a stream of consciousness
with you guys
thanks
for being here